[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and once upon a
time in Hollywood is shaking of the
movie industry with its star-studded
cast and alternate ending that changes
the facts to fiction throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the ending
of the movie and discussing how it
alters the actual events of the Manson
murders and death of Sharon Tate there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't seen the film yet and don't want
to know what happens then I highly
suggest that you turn off now
there are some typical Tarantino s
twists here and the surprises are worth
seeing unspoiled so this is your last
chance to enjoy the film with fresh eyes
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into my breakdown of Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood is set to the backdrop
of the infamous Manson murders
particularly the death of Sharon Tate
however the film is somewhat satirical
and similar to inglorious basterds the
film gives the truth a rather more
Hollywood ending the movie itself
follows Rick Dalton and his best friend
cliff booth played by Leonardo DiCaprio
and Brad Pitt respectively and Dalton
who was once at the top of his game now
realizes that his career is going on a
complete downward spiral the film
chronicles his journey to what he thinks
is the bottom rung of the ladder and
along the way he and Booth bump into the
likes of many big real names in
Hollywood including Bruce Lee they also
meet Catherine cher played by Lena
Dunham who just so happens to be the
ringleader of the Manson girls which
plays into the end of the film on the
whole though the tale is mostly
fictional and after dalton ends up
getting married he in booth decide to
part ways but they want just one more
night of drinking to celebrate all
they've been through together this just
so happens to be on August the 8th which
is my birthday by the way if you want to
buy a car or smash that like button
thank you very much and this is of
course the infamous night that the four
followers of Charles Manson decided to
murder Sharon Tate who just so happens
to be a neighbor of Dahl
in real life they went on to kill Tate
and her houseguests and Manson did this
to try and frame the Black Panthers in
order to start a race war that would
eventually lead to the apocalypse known
as helter skelter though in real life
the murders did happen Manson and his
followers were eventually jailed before
the situation could escalate any more
and he and the group went down in
history as some of the worst serial
killers of all time however the film
completely changes the events from about
this point onwards and paints out
history with rose tinted glasses during
the bender Rick who is sick and tired of
all the hippies goes face to face with
the killers who parked up outside the
houses and he orders them to leave which
they do that doesn't mean it's over
though and the group of murderers come
up with a new plan on Manson's orders to
kill Rick instead to them it doesn't
really matter who the target is as long
as their messages spread so they head
back to his house the killers returned
to the house but what we get instead of
some brutal murders is some over-the-top
highly graphic violence that has its
tongue place firmly in its cheek it's
all-out war with Rick his wife cliff and
the dog all getting into it with the
acolytes eventually they manage to kill
them and overcome the threat and Tate
who lives just next door overhears the
ruckus and goes out to find what
happened Rick knows that she's married
to Roman Polanski but till now he hasn't
really had the opportunity to speak to
her however this is the perfect
introduction to finally get talking to
her and to get his career back on track
the film ends with the two chatting away
like old friends and we get a happy
ending that basically rewrites history
and makes Rick the hero of his own movie
it's an awesome ending that in true
Tarantino fashion that lets us look back
on the past with wishful thinking and
makes us wonder what we could have got
had the events played out differently on
the whole the movie actually does stick
to the facts in terms of the main
players with all of the killers
including Tex Watson Susan Atkins Linda
Kasabian and Katie all having real-life
counterparts on the night that they were
going to commit the murders though there
was no Rick Dalton and thus the group
were able to carry out their brutal
killings though Polanski was a target at
the time he was actually away during the
murders and the group killed Tate who
was eight months pregnant
and all of our party guests the killings
were very brutal and I definitely
recommend that you watch one of the many
YouTube documentaries on the matter if
this movie has piqued your interest but
what does it all mean well to me the
entire film is a quest for fame and it
shows how in order to get it and hold on
to it we have to do terrible things
Dalton and the Manson's are focused
solely on gaining recognition and tried
to keep a hold of it as tightly as
possible and to me this symbolizes just
how Hollywood subverts the innocent in
exchange for status the movie business
as a whole is all about the flavor of
the month and in the form even though
Tate is currently popular we get the
feeling that deep down she knows she
won't be forever overall to me this
movie is a comment on how Hollywood
romanticizes these aspects and paint it
all out to be one big happy ending even
though we as an audience know that this
is never the case just as Tarantino
changed history Hollywood does this too
and the piece should be viewed as a
parody of how the movie business as a
whole is unwilling to show it's dark on
the side even though we know it all
exists in the end once upon a time in
Hollywood is a fascinating look at the
film industry and I definitely recommend
that you go and see it this weekend
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this take and if you agree with me
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my breakdown of
the upcoming MCU Marvel phase 5 slate
which would be linked at the end in it I
got over all of the confirmed films for
the future lineup so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more I'll leave that linked in the end
card and hopefully I'll see over there
after this if you want to come talk to
me directly or just want to see my
general thoughts of movies TV shows and
games then make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey I also just
want to let you know that we're giving
away a free copy of a vengeance and game
on blu-ray to one lucky winner and all
you have to do is like this video make
sure that you subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood in the comments
section below the one will be chosen at
random on August the 10th and the
blu-ray will be shipped out from then to
ever get surprised it's the best of luck
to everyone who takes part
this is the channel for people who were
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]